[Music]
it's all about competition you know you
got to compete you know you got to
compete to be the best whether that's in
sports or it's in business
I'm Derek Jeter former shortstop of the
New York Yankees and now partner at
Arena Club
I played 23 professional years in
baseball and that's just a small portion
of your life you got a long life to live
afterwards so I think you have to make
sure you prepare yourself for that I
started thinking about post baseball
life Maybe
10 years prior to my retirement you know
I I've always been one that prided
myself on being prepared and I didn't
want to wake up when my playing career
was over and say what am I going to do
next my time on the field was most
important but I definitely started
thinking about what's next
my thoughts went to ownership team
ownership so what I tried to do is learn
as much as I possibly could about an
organization I lived in Florida next to
the Yankees Player Development complex
so I learned as much as I could about
Player Development scouting analytics
you know during my career made every
decision when it came to contract
negotiations marketing PR these are all
pillars of an organization biggest
lesson I wouldn't say it's any lesson
that any new lesson I've learned look
it's all about people it's all about who
you surround yourself with it's all
about having the same goals and
aspirations and work ethic so whether
you're on the field you're off the field
it's all the same you know business and
professional sports very similar
[Music]
current advice I would say is meet as
many people as you can I ask a lot of
questions and I think you learn through
experiences you learn through people
what you're passionate about when you
have that platform of playing a
professional sport one thing that you
get is access and if you have that
access I think you should meet as many
people as you can you know you play
sports you turn 30 years old people tell
you how old you are and then when you
retire you become young again so I knew
I had a long life to live after my
playing career
got three young girls right now and I
want to be present with them and their
lives I just don't necessarily think I
have the time to commit to doing what I
was doing when I was in my family I
think that's the most important I want
to be there for my girls help them find
out what they're passionate about and be
there to support them
[Music]